foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
my name is Karen so glad that you are
here tonight here and hello to the
people joining us online
um and you know gold stars for all of
you for braving the rain or at least the
remnants of the rain to get here tonight
I know on nights with weather like this
I just want to nap
and snack and watch TV so good you know
good for us for being here tonight
um I have a few announcements and uh
ways to get connected here at the table
starting tonight going through the month
of September first of all tonight is
first Sunday it's the first Sunday of
the month and yeah that is tradition for
us to go out and eat together after the
service so you were all invited we will
head over to hat Creek Burger Company in
Sachse it is five minutes up the road
it's on the corner of 78 and Woodbridge
we all go out to eat it has a place for
the kids to play and it's another way
just to continue connecting and meeting
each other and talking after the service
is over so I hope you will join us for
that it's always a good time
secondly
we have our
bi-annual state of the table meeting
coming up on September 18th that's
another after the service type thing and
think of the State of the Union only
really tiny because it's us here at the
table we're not talking about the whole
country but our our community here and
if you're a member at the table that is
something to to attend if you are
interested in becoming a member at the
table or if you have any interest about
the table at all this is a great meeting
to be at we talk through our mission
vision and values we get a chance to
hear from our ministry team leaders talk
about the finances
it is the state of the table and how
we're doing so again that'll be in a
couple weeks after the service and we'd
love to have you be a part of that
and then the lastly who do we have in
here that is a table teen
our 12 years and up crowd cool
Matthew
you're one of those two
on his phone anyways
um we are kicking off our table teen
Meetup tomorrow
so yay
um and who do we have in here that's on
the table teen leadership group
Maggie
Marissa is out in the foyer
and we also have Michael and Abby it's a
great leadership team the teams are
going to get together tomorrow to do
some fun things food movies lots of
games so if you it's going to be
tomorrow and have we figured out a time
yet for that
yeah Okay cool so afternoon late
afternoon eveningish is the time frame
if you are interested in being a part of
that and you have not yet connected with
Maggie please see her after the service
she'll get you all the details and if
you're going to hat Creek you can also
talk to her then sound good
all right well as we move into worship
let's take a moment just to take a
breath
yes take a breath
relax you're here you made it
you are welcome here
let's close our eyes
whatever is on the to-do list later
today tomorrow the coming week press
pause on that be here now foreign
your heart and your mind to settle
you are loved you are worthy
God thank you for tonight
thank you for this time together
[Music]
thank you God that you are a firm
foundation no matter what we're going
through and we are never alone
God thank you for the hope that we can
find in you
and that by just continuing to show up
have courage to take it another day at a
time God you meet us right there
so whatever it is that we've walked in
with God we lay that at your feet
we exhale
and we inhale your spirit your goodness
your love your presence
God help us to hear from you tonight
and whatever it is that's needed right
now rest
hope forgiveness
favor healing
restoration Redemption
we find that in you God
that is who you are
[Music]
so thank you God for being with us thank
you for this community of friendship
and love
and I pray that we would continue to
lean into that
especially in the tough times
may we carry each other's burdens may we
rejoice in each other's Joys and
everything in between
in Jesus name I pray amen
Karen well if you guys would like to
stand with us we're going to go ahead
and get started on brighter days and if
you're new to the table this is Jesse
and this is Maggie and I'm Mindy and
this is a time for us to All Join it
together thank you Nikki that's Nikki in
the back bringing in the back of the
worship team
so anyways you guys just join in there's
room for your voice there's room for
whatever you bring in to this space
tonight
[Music]
excited day
I swear the Love Will Find you in your
pain all right first of all that's hard
to do I just did that
[Music]
means
oh ashes
[Music]
I know there's gonna be some brighter
days
[Music]
[Applause]
I know there's gonna be some brighter
days
oh it feels screams
are crashing down
whoa if your heart just cries too loud
all the time
[Music]
I swear the Love Will Find you in your
days
[Music]
foreign
gonna be surprised
[Music]
I know there's gonna be
some
brighter days
[Music]
all right we're actually going to do a
new song Tonight
and um the title is Psalm 116 and that's
because the lyrics are derived almost
straight out of it so I just wanted to
read these first two verses for you it
says I love the Lord for he heard my
voice
he heard my cry for Mercy because he
turned his ear to me I will call on him
as long as I live
um yeah if you have kids they're welcome
to go to their class now sorry I almost
but um that verse has been ringing in my
head as I've played this song uh over
and over throughout this week just
getting ready for it and preparing and I
was thinking about how there are
definitely appropriate times
um if nowhere else than in the church
for us to be honest and name our pain
and our troubles and our sorrows and and
that should always be true it should
never be something that we just sit up
on a shelf and pretend like it's not
happening or it's not there that should
always be true and with that also we
should take time to remember the moments
that God turned his ear towards us the
moments where we felt Deliverance the
moments where we felt his presence and
his closeness and we should also name
those not only for ourselves but for
each other to help lift each other up
because
we don't need anyone else to tell us
that this world is broken and we are
broken and we sense that we feel it
right I mean you can't escape that
reality
but with that reality also comes the
goodness of God and that he is our
Center and he will hold and we've got to
go back to that Foundation that
centerpiece and remember why it is that
we're believing in this God why it is
that we are anchoring Our Lives to this
gospel it's because of his goodness and
his love and his acceptance his
forgiveness so tonight let's take a
moment even amidst all the things that
may be going wrong in your world let's
take a moment to recall the goodness of
God and and sing this scripture over our
lives and encourage ourselves and each
other
[Music]
for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living
[Music]
I love you Lord for you have delivered
me
[Music]
I love you Lord
for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
Death
from stumbling
I will walk in the land of the living
[Music]
and I will bless you Lord for you heard
my cry I reach out my head and you saved
my life
[Music]
for you have delivered me
I
Love You Lord
For You have delivered my soul from
Death
from stumbling I will walk in the land
of the living my soul from Death my feet
of the living
foreign
[Music]
we're going to move into the prayers of
the people
if you're with us online we encourage
you to leave comments and we will share
those with the room
[Music]
can you guys read this aloud with me
for this city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them we pray to you
for the Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
an orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
foreign
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
[Music]
I love you Lord
for your mercies never fail me
and all my days I've been held in your
hands
the moment that I wake up
till I lay my head
I will see
of the goodness
God
let's sing that together
I love you Lord
for your mercy never fails me
and all my days I've been held in your
hands
moments that I wake up
until I lay my head
I will sing of the goodness of God
oh my life you have in faith
all my life you have been so so
good
with every breath
I will see of the goodness of
us I love your voice
you have led me through the fire
in darkest nights you are close like no
other
I've known you as a father
[Music]
friend
though my life you have been there
[Music]
all my life
with every breath that I made
[Music]
your goodness is
your goodness
[Music]
in my life you have been faithful
thank you
and all my life you have been so so good
with every breath that I made
I will sing of the goodness of God
I will see
of the goodness of God
[Music]
Jesus tonight would you remind us of the
times where
we can't explain anything except that
your love was there
the times that don't make sense except
that you showed up and did the thing
that only you do
whether it was healing or restoration
[Music]
and God I just want to remember
that the times when that's not happening
doesn't change who you are
it doesn't change how faithful and
committed your love is
and help me not to attach my
circumstances to you
[Music]
but instead to attach you and you
that we are
[Music]
God help us to live into that reality
foreign
to believe for more when everything else
says not to
to look for light in the midst of
Darkness to find Hope and to be hope for
others
when hope has run out
[Music]
thank you God for who you are
for your constant love
we trust it and we ask that it be
present in every moment of
that we would find it that we would look
for it search for it
invited in
open our ears and our eyes tonight God
help us to hear what's on your heart
give Brett words
that are straight from you
we love you
and we ask all this in Jesus name
[Music]
foreign
well good evening
Grace and peace there we go good evening
grace and peace try it again
um
well welcome everyone it is so good to
be with you all and
um you know I wanted to just name
I don't know like maybe you find
yourself
um kind of here in this space tonight
and just feeling kind of discouraged
um one of the uh the great like kind of
gifts I get as a as a pastor is to be in
touch with many of you via uh text
and um because this I get to hear you
know like what's going on in people's
lives and that might
um which means you know the high moments
and the like moments of Victory and
breakthrough and then
um also they're like really low
um discouraging moments and um and that
you know that might sound kind of uh
like maybe I don't know difficult or
something to you know receive that but
honestly
um even in the like low moments
um I've like been able to track so many
of your stories through I mean for some
of you more than just months but like
even years now and what's so beautiful
is to see that like even at those low
moments how faithful God is to like
continually bring us through
and I just want to name like if you're
in a place tonight where you maybe you
just feel just incredibly discouraged
and beat down and you're like this is I
am I'm just done
um I I just want to name like in just a
second everything we were just singing
and declaring about who God is
um God is is faithful to be with you in
the midst of it and
um I am trusting I've seen it a hundred
times
uh God brings people through it so I
just want to just name and give you that
um that hope tonight so um my name is
Brett I'm the passenger here like I
already said and um
I want to welcome not only
um all of you here but also just join us
online I love you all lots and and
anyone here who's new thank you for
being with us uh you are your wanted
you're welcome here in this this place
tonight uh so don't feel like a stranger
or an outsider though I know that is a
very you know natural thing to feel but
um just just know that we we really want
you here
um
so we're actually next week we're going
to be kicking off a new series uh and
I'm very excited for it's going to be
titled unclean and if you've been around
the table for a while you know we do
different types of series sometimes we
like join the church calendar and we'll
do you know like lent um or you know
series on Easter or something like that
um at other times we'll go through like
a book of the Bible like we just
finished first Peter uh last week
so um and then we'll do like more
topical Series this one's going to be a
little bit unique and that what I'm
going to do is use a book of the same
title unclean um written by someone I
quote often the the Christian and
psychologist Richard Beck and he has
wrote a wonderful book I mean it's just
incredible and I thought I need to do a
theories on this since I know if I like
which I did this week I put in my e
letter I was like read this book get
this book it's great but I know y'all
are busy like five percent perhaps less
are actually going to get the book and
read even among the readers like even if
you're like I am a reader of books I
know your book list is like a hundred
books long if you're anything like me
I'm like obsessed and someone book list
it just gets out of control I just have
to scrap it every few years like fresh
start start over there's like things
from five years value
um so I I get it so that's what I'm
gonna do is kind of take that book and
what I want to do is
um kind of take the scriptures
specifically some of the passages from
the gospels and kind of um bring the
book and then those scriptures together
and appreciate as like a four week
Series so um that will be next week and
I'm I'm very very excited for it
um so uh with that in mind though
tonight is kind of just a one-off
um message and it's gonna it's titled
um turning wine into water
you heard that right for those familiar
with Jesus Miracle you think uh oh typo
nope uh you'll you'll see in a moment
where we're going with this
um so I want to give this is really uh a
message kind of on the book of Galatians
um we'll be in chapter six specifically
but I want to give you some background
for those unfamiliar with the book of
Galatians so it's um basically we have
preserved in the New Testament this
letter by uh a gentleman now he's known
as in some traditions Saint Paul or
Apostle Paul uh back then he was just
like Paul and um he planted some
Churches in the city of galatia he wrote
a letter to them and we have it
preserved in the New Testament and kind
of what was going on at that that time
in this church most of them were um what
are known as like Gentiles right
non-jewish people
um and so that came came from very
diverse religious backgrounds and such
but there were some Jewish Christians
among them and um the those Jewish
Christians they believed like Jesus is
um uh wasn't is Messiah uh that you know
we receive the Holy Spirit and um we
need to rely on the spirit to you know
for every part of our lives uh so they
they believe that but they they said but
but
also to be a truly fully
um biblical Christian
um you also need to do some other things
um for example they wanted the males to
practice um circumcision which goes back
to like Old Testament
um law and such uh to follow certain
food laws you know eating Kosher foods
avoiding unkoshed funds uh and keep
Sabbath keeping and things like that
um so so they you know believed Christ
but also said like but you also have to
do some other things
um now Paul who had planted these
churches he himself had come from a
Jewish background so he had thought long
and hard on this
and um he disagreed now today we kind of
take for granted that this would be the
case back then this was like a hotly
contested
um topic because you know God
um gave Commandments and well you're
just gonna ignore Moses
you're all gonna ignore Moses you're
like I've seen the Ten Commandments that
guy was very powerful
um so you know you can imagine back then
this was kind of a thing and it became a
thing in that church
um because it kind of started to
introduce the sort of two-tier
Christianity in a way you know it was
like they were the really
spiritual ones who really were truly
biblical in the rich since and then they
were like you know some others
um and so Paul had thought long and hard
on this and he he really disagreed and
he said look
um
uh in one place he called he says Jesus
um is the image of the invisible God
he says and that Christ has come among
us he has lived he has died on the cross
for sins he has
um been resurrected to remove any
barrier or hindrance we could ever
actually have or even just imagine we
could have from God I mean it's all the
things we were thinking tonight the
goodness of God the grace of God the
Forgiveness of God like God is present
and and available to each of you I mean
it's like he said like that's the case
um and it's through the life the death
the resurrection of Jesus and he said so
uh wait so you think you're going to
like add to that work
like you know it's for Jesus plus these
things he's like
no no no
all right so that's the background
um that you need so let's read our our
text this is Galatians chapter six
um verses 15 through 18 towards the end
of the book he said um this it doesn't
matter
whether we have been circumcised or not
what counts is whether we have been
transformed
into a new creation
may God's peace and mercy be upon all
who live by this principle they are the
new people of God
can hear well that um we'll get to this
later but Paul has a very inclusive
vision of the people of God because it's
not trying to uh name who's not included
he's just saying like no no through
Christ
we're all included
everyone's welcome they are the new
people of God from now on don't let
anyone trouble me with these things he
spent a lot of years working this
through and arguing with people on it
don't let anyone trouble me with these
things for I bear on my body the scars
that show I belong to Jesus
dear brothers and sisters May the grace
of our Lord Jesus Christ be with your
spirit amen
so I want to kind of frame this up
because I really want to meditate on
verse 15 with you tonight I want to
frame this with a a wonderful quote from
the Danish writer Thorne Kierkegaard who
lived much he was writing in like the
1800s he was I think if I remember
correctly a Dane so he was from like the
Netherlands and had the Danish like
State church at that time and security
guard was a committed Christian but whoa
he could have it in for the church he
was you've ever read anything by him and
he's one of those uh he's he's witty
he's a he's a good writer so um so this
is is what critiquing the the church of
his day swearing kierkegon writes this
he says whereas Christ
turned the water into wine
the church has succeeded in doing
something more difficult
it has turned wine into water
um I think this is brilliant what he's
what he's naming I mean basically that's
the book of Galatians it's kind of like
what we just talked about you might even
say it's like the journey
um kind of of Christianity over and over
and over again
um that we we keep having this tendency
to take
um
to take God's good new wine and we just
like figure out a way to turn it back
into water again
um now I know for some of you perhaps
you're like I'm a little bit lost I
don't actually know what he means by
wine and water and so I realize I'm
being a little unclear so let me like
unpack some of this and of course this
is I think a very rich kind of quote
um there's other thing I'm not saying
I'm like an exhaust the meeting tonight
but just I just want to give you a few
kind of um a little bit of food for
thought so and the way I actually want
to do it is by talking about it in the
reverse what does um water into wine
actually look like in like our world in
the church and things like that um so
what does it actually look like um when
we're talking about water into wine I
think we're talking about the transition
or the move from law into Grace from
complexity
to simplicity
from exclusion to inclusion from rules
to the spirit
and I think what you can tell from the
book of Galatians is Paul adores this
whole transition Paul really really
likes water into wine and
um I think you can kind of see that I'm
going to give you a few quotes on each
of these like from the book of Galatians
where he kind of unpacks this and it's a
lot of scripture I promise I'm going
somewhere it will apply to your lives
but just hang with me for a few minutes
so okay so this move from law to Grace
what's he what what is Paul getting at
Paul writes about this move from the
water of law to the wine of Grace in
this way this is Galatians chapter 5
verse 4. he says for if you are trying
to make yourselves right with God by
keeping the law I realized I said trying
that's very Texan that's not in the text
he said trying
um trying if you're trying to make
yourselves right with God by keeping the
law you have been cut off from Christ
you have fallen away from what from
God's grace it's almost like God's just
giving you this this gift and you're
like no don't worry I'm awesome enough I
can really you know I can earn this you
know he's like I'm just trying to give
it to you
and it's weird how we can almost exclude
ourselves like we can distance ourselves
from God's grace
um Paul loves this move from Water to
Wine he loves he describes this on this
move from the water of complexity to the
wine of Simplicity in this way this is
um Galatians
um five verse 6 B uh what is important
is Faith expressing itself in love in
other words sometimes I think we can get
overwhelmed even with just the sheer
length of the Bible like oh my gosh I
don't even know what to do and it's I
think he's just bringing us back to
something very simple it's faith in
Christ
that Christ loves me
um cares for me died for me rose again
for me welcomes me into God's family and
I receive that beautiful love and then I
seek to express it and live it out
another place Paul will say it's about
faith hope and love which I think you'll
agree is still you know pretty simple
um he talks about this this move from
the water of exclusion to the wine of
inclusion this way this is Galatians 2
verses 11 through 12. it says but when
Peter is actually kind of a story it
says but when Peter who you know like
the 12 disciples Peter you know he
became like the leader of the church in
Jerusalem he was a big deal
says this but when Peter came to Antioch
I had to oppose him to his face
got the disciples fighting for what he
did was very wrong when he first arrived
he ate with the Gentile believers
those who are not circumcised but
afterwards when some friends of James
came Peter wouldn't eat with the
Gentiles anymore he was afraid of
criticism from these people who insisted
on the necessity of circumcision you can
kind of see where he's critiquing it
he's basically saying like Peter don't
you dare turn that wine back into water
again right you can hear that Paul he
loves this move from water into wine
finally he describes the transition from
the the water of rule following to the
wine of the spirit
um in this way this is Galatians 2 verse
25 or sorry 5 25. since we are living by
the spirit let us follow the spirits
leading in every part of our Lives you
see Paul loves this move from water to
wine and honestly I think most everyone
I think like at least what initially
strikes me is like I think we love this
move from Water to Wine um it seems
every maybe even the whole world maybe
everyone loves Water to Wine it seems
except and here I will pick on um my own
group I'm a pastor representing you know
Church leadership I think
I get a little worked up on this
it seems everyone loves Water to Wine
except so many church leaders like it's
in what we'll get more we'll kind of
unpack this more in a second
um but it just it seems to me there are
too many pastors priests Bishops
self-proclaimed Apostles certainly tell
evangelists who who keep taking God's
new wine God's Good gospel the good news
and like somehow turn it into bad news
for like a lot of people and this is a
huge problem like it's just two it's we
just have this knack for like
um making new hoops for people to jump
through
this is a huge issue
like it's like my own folks we just
don't get it
um
now y'all have if you've been with me a
while you know
I'm all for a good critique of the
church but I won't ever let it rest
there
um and I do wonder if at times even
maybe in my own vehemence against the
church which just to be clear I'm not
going back on I just said I think it's
true but what's that they say about the
whole one finger you know one finger
pointed out there and then the three
back
um three there's three pointing back at
you
um I do
I do wonder if there is kind of Truth
um
in that part even even for us
um and I do wonder if sometimes not all
the time but sometimes we can have kind
of the punching bag of the church you
know those leaders you know and I'm
again almost we deserved probably
um but at times it can distance us you
know
um from the
from the problem
and um
there's a novel
um
that one of my faves yes I'm quoting it
again the brothers k
the brothers karamazov the most
wonderful of all novels I love this uh
by Dostoyevsky
um and in it there's like a little story
within a story it's a short story
written by one of the characters that he
reads to another character
and
um
so it's it's I mean it's it's
beautifully written but there's this uh
the basic kind of outline the story is
that
um
he's imagining that uh in a story that
Christ returns to earth
um but it's not like
we may be envisioned you know per Book
of Revelation or whatever kind of
apocalyptic imagery you want to draw on
with you know Jesus on the horse he's
got the sword and depending on your
interpretation it's his own blood or
it's others and he's playing his amazing
whatever
um it's not that it's not that instead
in this story Jesus
slips down into the honestly it's just
like kind of his first coming just quiet
and he
um takes up residence in an obscure town
in Spain
just quietly slips in the world and goes
about his healing work all over again
um starts spending time with the
outcasts and those you know on the edges
of society and bringing life and words
of encouragement and
um healing literally you know like
there's Miracles and pretty quickly the
people
um they recognize him
you know the common folks they're like
we know you
um but eventually word gets back
to the uh Church Christian church
leaders
and uh you know you might think they'd
be happy
but uh no when basically because they
realized like uh oh well if he's back
the whole game's up
and so what do they do they
condemn him to death
imprison him
schedule the date of his execution
and the night before his scheduled
execution a church higher up it's his
title is the grand Inquisitor
and he
comes to Jesus prison cell
and has this absolutely fascinating
dialogue though really it's more of a
monologue because just like in the
gospels Christ is mostly silent
throughout the whole thing
and so it's this
Church leader the grand Inquisitor kind
of monologuing
and
he tells Christ at one point he says um
you
you have made one mistake
you thought people
would want their freedom
but they do not
in fact they have come to us
and they have laid it at our feet
he said they want rules
they want loss
they want to know
who is in and who is out and it better
be clear and by golly there better be
some people out or else why am I going
through all this
and I read that short story and I
thought my goodness
what's he talking about he's naming that
there's a part of us that kind of likes
our water
we kind of like our water
I might put it this way I'll kind of
close that with just a few
um points here
at the end of the day it seems that we
prefer
our clicks and our tribes our identities
as Texans and gosh darn it as Americans
rather than the radical welcome of a new
creation community
this goes right back to
Galatians 6 and the whole the whole
circumcision argument
um right for them like circumstances it
started off as this way to kind of
um name a people and people are going to
be faithful to God but like over time it
became this the well the weird thing
that seems humans are so good at
creating in groups and out groups and
then feeling real good about ourselves
when we're the end group you know and we
just keep we just keep doing this only
of course maybe like for us it's
different you know
um it's no longer maybe that symbol but
we just you know we have like our own
don't we
um like we still kind of in our own way
we love the idea and this will be more
our next theories we kind of love the
idea of the pure group you know the the
pure
um political party or the pure church or
the pure friend group or the the pure
tribe you know where we're all in and we
keep those people out
um and we just we just keep
longing for that water
but
God in his goodness
through Christ
continues to say no no no no
I'm taking that water and I'm turning it
and I'm offering you new wine I'm
calling you to something more everyone
is welcome in my church everyone has a
place Christ says
the table I don't just mean this
community I mean the big table
God's big tent Christianity it's
sometimes called
like there there is room for people
all of you are united in Christ
the idea of that
do that until like all the different
people start showing up and it's kind of
like whoa that's
[Music]
oh we love our water and I'm not putting
this on y'all I love my water too I do
at the end of the day it seems number
two we prefer so often our formulas are
hard work
our sense of entitlement over the new
creation experience of being saved by
God's grace
again for early Christians it was like
you know Jesus plus you know
circumcision and and food laws and
Sabbath keeping and you know and again
for us it's different
um but it's just I know but it's just it
just morphs in a new generation and it's
like I don't know whatever awesome not
awesome kind of weird things well they
can be good enough themselves but it's
when we start messing with them in this
way and making them like new Hoops for
people to jump through in order to come
to God you know all of a sudden it's
like what you don't read the King James
Bible oh what are you thinking you know
what you don't vote for such and such
political party well I don't even know
if you're saved you know like can you
see where we just keep doing this
like
oh y'all it's an issue but um even uh
speaking in tongues can be this
um taking communion every week
can be this
pursuing Justice
the way you know I think it should be
done you know I just we just keep we
keep doing
but Jesus in his goodness
and his grace
he takes that water and he says no no
I'm I'm making that into new wine I I'm
turning this into wine it is Grace and
the goodness of God all the way down for
us
all the way down
that's so often
we kind of love our water don't we
at the end of the day it seems third and
finally we kind of prefer often our
rules and our Earthly authorities
over the new creation freedom and
guidance of the Holy Spirit
and for first century Christians it was
different like maybe certain Old
Testament scriptures the law of Moses
whatever it was for us it's different
maybe we all kind of want to Guru it
seems you know like someone to tell us
exactly what to do
you know what I mean like just get I
think this is even the um like we
like how we all kind of need a model
of like I don't mean like a fashion
model but I mean you know like the the
person I'm gonna model my life after
and
um it's interesting now so often even as
Christians it's like someone other than
Christ
you know even pastors come to play this
role a lot I say that as though you
don't know even pastors now we know this
right this is this can be the phenomena
of
um
yeah we just keep looking to human
authorities
but Jesus in his goodness
says oh no I am pouring out my spirit on
All Flesh every single one of you
God is speaking to you
and God is leading you and God is
equipping you in giving you everything
you need to love him to follow him to be
faithful to live a beautiful meaningful
love centered god-centered life
because he's just that good
he's just that good and so I kind of
Wonder tonight like
what could God do with a group of people
who say okay
yes I kind of like that water but God I
want your new one
I want it
I wonder what that would do to this
community
to our families
our friend circles our places of work
speak those kinds of people
so as we come to the table
of the Lord tonight as we take in the
body of Christ and the bread the blood
of Christ in the wine
May um may this be an opportunity in a
moment
for
us to say God I want your new wine
I want your new one I'm tired of that
water
I've been like live in that um
just a dead form of religiosity
been living it for too long I want your
new wine
so that's the that's the invitation
tonight
um
for those who maybe haven't been here we
practice what's called an Open Table
meaning if you want to come forward
tonight to participate to practice
communion then you are welcome to do
that
no religious Hoops to jump through
no one will check your doctrinal
credentials before you come forward
and um
let me invite you forward with this
invitation
this is the table
not of the church
not of the church which has a way of
taking that wine and making it into
water
this is the table
of the Lord
It's Made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
um
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here
come to the table
good
foreign
[Music]
thank you
we're going to close by finishing with
this song by Michael Gungor and he
always has a way of turning things on
their head for me and reminding me to
think bigger about the gospel and think
bigger about the words of Jesus and the
way that I interpret them
and it's kind of like one of those
things where it's a good mirror for you
because it kind of shows you your
filters that you might not even realize
that you have
at least for me so I encourage you maybe
later to go look up this song and the
lyrics
um maybe play it sometime this week and
just have a quiet moment with it
um at least for me it's been very
helpful to
um to just reveal maybe some of the ways
that I'm trying to
take that wine and turn it back into
water
um if you know the song please sing it
along with us if not feel free to just
sit back and enjoy
[Music]
they try to keep you in a tent they
could not keep you in a temple or any of
their Idols to see and understand
we cannot keep you in a church we cannot
keep you in a Bible
it's just another Idol
please
could not keep you in their walls we
could not keep you in ours either
you are so much greater
[Music]
who is
with the poor
lifts them From the Ashes
[Music]
who is like the Lord
tried to keep you in
try to keep you in our temples we've
worshiped all our Idols we want all that
to end
we will find you in the
English we will find you in the prisons
and even in our Bibles our churches and
who is like the Lord
who dwells with the poor
lives them From the Ashes
[Music]
of your name
is
[Music]
who is like the Lord
took me From the Ashes
healed me from my blindness
who is like the Lord
[Music]
thanks so much for being here tonight
remember after the service we're going
to be heading over to hat Creek Burger
Company in Sachse five minutes down the
road would love to see you there we'll
have a couple people who leave
immediately after the service
and I think Angie is that you Angie back
here if you turn and look at Angie she
will be there and she's going to have
some tables reserved for us so you can
look for Angie when you get there you'll
know where to sit
um also if you are visiting with us
tonight before you leave right as you
walk out the door there's a little itty
bitty wooden table with a box on it grab
a visitor card it says the table flip it
over please put your name and your
contact information help us to get in
contact with you this week we'd love to
be able to do that and welcome you a
little bit more fully to the community
if you are comfortable and able to do so
if you could stand to your feet I would
love to send you out into your week with
this benediction
that I believe is true for each and
every single one of you here tonight and
watching online
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
love
and Grace and compassion and inclusion
to everyone you meet
be blessed have a great week go to hat
Creek for dinner tonight and we hope to
see you back here next Sunday good night
thank you
[Music]
foreign